all right joining us now with reaction
civil rights attorney Darryl parks and
turning-point USA communications
director
Candace Owens is in studio so great to
have you you actually are part of this
story
Kanye first offended you that is
absolutely right apparently it was my
brain that launched this ideological
civil war in the black community and I
am so excited about it this is a
tremendous time to be alive as a black
American we've been existing under this
facade these lies the Democrats have
orchestrated because they consider us a
low information voters market you know
and they so they think we're not going
to research the stats and we'll never
find out I hate the race card it's
played every election year absol
everything an election it drives me nuts
you know 14 states Darryl now have
record low unemployment record low black
Americans record low Hispanic Americans
record low women in America record low
unemployment records that is since
Donald Trump was elected president of
the United States is that good for
America Obama had eight years 13 million
more Americans on food stamps 8 million
more Americans in poverty that was his
legacy who's doing a better job Bush
who's doing a better job well Sean first
of all who I don't know how President
Trump could take responsibility for that
progress doesn't deal with the real
issue the real issue is that black
Americans are still having great
difficulty in the unemployment for
myself every forgotten man and woman has
a job and a trajectory to the life they
want in this great free country you're
not answering my questions look at these
numbers now with 13 million more
Americans on food stamps that he fell
did he fail with 8 million more in
poverty eight years later he did not
fail at all he did not feel alive I
think what he did black America focus
what I want to see though is President
Trump to show us that black Americans
are priority for him and the house
specifics as to how he plans to gun it
they're issues of issue and it's okay
actually like when they do this have
these delusional responses just admit
that the people blacks are doing better
under the trump presidency that's
totally fine but it's this refusal to
admit it and blacks you're going to
start doing the research and they're
going to start easy
going on I have been frustrated Al Gore
Republicans don't even want to count you
in the census or you know the change in
tone and cadence before predominantly
black American audiences I always
thought was insulting but the policies
you know wish look at the what Kanye
said four thousand American soul
slaughtered in Chicago we once called
the names we heard about Trayvon Martin
and George Zimmerman we heard about
Freddie gray Baltimore we heard about
Ferguson I scrolled the names we never
heard of these four thousand people shot
and killed
oh listen that's because Chicago was run
by Democrats and they never want to hold
up a mirror to what they're doing so
that's why we never heard those names
4,000 that's exactly right that's the
exact same number about the same number
of Americans that were slaughtered in
the Iraq war right it's a war zone and
Trump offered to send the National Guard
and the Democrats majorly opposed him so
when it comes down to is Trump is trying
to be effective there and we're seeing
that we have so many great results in
black America because you say to Daryl
but Shawn let me say this though I want
to hear for my president to tell us that
something about black America is a
priority for him tomorrow I would love
to hear in focus on mental health
education health care those are issues
that he can help us with tomorrow Obama
care work those issues it sounds like
deciding ears of Trump that's what
really comes down to because he's doing
a great job the numbers are better and
he needs more time in office to continue
to do an amazing job so it sounds like
you're almost aboard the Trump train
which makes me feel happy we're agreeing
on something here let me say something I
want to see Trump be successful but this
is our country but I don't think he is
focusing on the issues that really
affect black America I hope he would
know so then you must agree that Obama
was not focusing whatsoever on the
issues that were affecting black America
if you don't think that Trump is right
now because the numbers are in and
blacks are doing better under his
administration
I love President Obama I don't think we
spent any more time trying to put him
down I think it's important to show that
things are a lot different and it's
important because they for so long they
have told us that because there was a
black president this meant progress
progress is not a skintone progress is a
number okay and for so long we've been
convinced look he's taking a photo op
with Beyonce in
that means absolutely nothing Chicago
got worse while Obama wasn't office and
he came from there that's what I mean
you you can't dispute the fact this
cultural shift is this gonna happen
we're on the brink of a cultural shift
and I can tell you right now it is going
to be amazing to watch I'm so happy you
put the darts with the single tweet and
I did predict it I think Holly west
would be the last time when I
interviewed you earlier in the week it's
gonna be fun to watch your trajectory
and your rise you're a superstar and
it's an honor to know you and have you
and I still like Daryl even though we
disagree on everything they're all good
to see you